making movies is a Gamble and some
Productions are simply dealt losing
hands whether they were impacted by the
pandemic or just didn't get enough butts
and seats these recent films flopped at
the box office but that doesn't mean
they're not worth your time when it was
announced that James gun would be
helming 2021s the suicide squad some
fans thought that it would end up making
more money than the critically hated
film that came out 5 years earlier sadly
however this was far from the case
Warner Brothers spent $185 million
producing the film and an estimated $100
million in marketing but it only brought
in a total of $168 million at the box
office worldwide profitable or not the
suicide squad is still a violent good
time its R rating allows for some
creatively bloody death sequences and
plenty of profanity but it still has the
same humor and heart that made guns
Guardians of the Galaxy Trilogy so
popular standout characters include
Sylvester Stallone's adorably deadly
king shark David dealin's self-loathing
polka dot man and John Cena's stubbornly
intense Peacemaker the latter of whom
even got his own spin-off show of course
the true star of the show is Margot
Robbie's Harley Quinn who takes out an
entire Palace full of guards in one
delightfully Twisted sequence it may not
have blown up the box office but the
suicide squad is still one of the better
DC films of the 2020s so far consider
considering its 90% critic rating on
Rotten Tomatoes there's no denying that
it deserved much more
success no one likes a show off unless
what they're showing off is dope
as when it was released on March 6th
2020 the Pixar film onward fared pretty
well at the box office at first then
covid-19 happened once it became
impossible to ignore the looming threat
of the pandemic movie goers began
staying home quickly putting a massive
dent in Disney's ticket sales on its
second weekend onward grossed only $10.5
million a record-breaking 74% drop from
its opening weekend given that the film
cost $200 million to produce its box
office Hall of
$41.99 was not enough to make it
profitable but that doesn't mean that
onward is a bad movie by any means after
all it has everything viewers have come
to expect from Pixar movies a unique
concept quality animation and a whole
lot of heart observant fans will
recognize the voices of Marvel movie
veterans Tom Holland and Chris Pratt as
lovable elf Brothers Ian and barley
Lightfoot and they make for a perfect
buddy comedy duo in fact there are lots
of memorable characters in this urban
fantasy world from a Tavern manager
Manor to a gang of Pixie bikers with a
bone to pick with our heroes of course
this film has more than just laughs to
offer thanks to the movie's bittersweet
ending onward will hit you in the fields
right when you least expect it when an
indie movie costs only $5 million to
make you'd think there's no way it can
lose but 2023 is BlackBerry did exactly
that the film earned just $1.6 million
worldwide proving that you don't need to
spend a fortune on a project for it to
flop at the box office elevation
pictures lost only a few million dollars
which is nothing compared to higher
profile bombs but this Savvy little Tech
comedy deserved better regardless of how
much money Blackberry made it's a
mustsee unlike the social network and
other biopics that take viewers behind
the scenes of a major technological
innovation Blackberry doesn't show an
industry Giant's humble Origins instead
the movie places everything in
perspective for audiences who already
know going in that the Blackberry will
go the way of the floppy disc watching a
tech Empire fall apart is arguably more
riveting than seeing its rise after all
although black Berry has several moving
Parts the film keeps its focus small
zeroing in on the main cast of
characters who got the Blackberry off
the ground Jay barell is excellent as
the tech expert behind the once popular
line of handheld devices and Glenn
Howton is perfect as the ruthless
businessmen who helped him conquer the
world before it all collapsed around
them you think I won't do it I'm from
waterl where the vampires hang out after
the smash success of ham on Broadway and
Disney plus it seemed reasonable to
expect ly Manuel Miranda's first musical
in the Heights to be a success when it
made the jump to the big screen alas
this was not the case as the film
couldn't make back its budget some
observers speculated that the slump in
ticket sales was because movie musicals
no longer have sway over audiences but
the fact that the film debuted
simultaneously on HBO Max may also have
had something to do with it with an
excellent cast and a Rotten Tomato score
well over 90% in the Heights certainly
deserved better the film is largely
faithful to the Broadway musical about
the people of the New York neighborhood
of Washington Heights with a few
additions there several new characters
an adorable framing device and a tragic
plot line involving one character's
status as an undocumented immigrant in
the Heights takes full advantage of its
medium translating the iconic dance
numbers of the original musical into
visually dazzling sequences on the big
screen one song manages to capture an
entire life while another features a
couple dancing on the side of a building
as fun as the stage version is the film
adaptation of in the Heights manages to
go above and beyond $384 million is a
lot of money and since that's the amount
that Indiana Jones in the dial of
Destiny made on a $300 million budget it
seems like the producers at least
managed to break even however that's not
accounting for the cost of marketing
some sources estimate that lucasfilm
spent anywhere from 6 $5 million to $200
million promoting the movie including $7
million just to purchase a Super Bowl TV
spot that made the fifth Indiana Jones
movie a box office disappointment
especially when compared to Indy's
earlier Adventures that doesn't mean
it's a bad movie not by a long shot
Harrison Ford doesn't let his Advanced
age stop him from playing everyone's
favorite archaeologist and he makes it
an important part of Indy's character
Phoebe Waller Bridge plays Helena Indy's
whip smart goddaughter and she makes for
a solid companion in a mission that will
determine the course of the future and
the past there are also cameos from some
of Indiana's colleagues from his
previous Journeys including Maran and
Salah the joy of seeing these familiar
faces again is mixed with a twinge of
sadness as we know their Glory days are
long behind
them and I miss waking up every morning
wondering what wonderful Adventure the
new day will bring to us Indiana Jones
and the dial of Destiny may not always
strike the right balance between homage
and originality but it certainly makes a
valiant effort Indiana Jones in the dial
of Destiny wasn't the only box office
flop of June
2023 The Flash also performed terribly
earning just $270 million worldwide that
kind of haul would be unbelievably
impressive for an indie film like
Blackberry but for one of the final
films in the DC extended Universe it was
a poultry sum the production budget of
the flash was $200 million
plus around $150 million for marketing
in other words it lost a mountain of
money The Flash isn't exactly the best
Multiverse movie in fact it's not even
the best Multiverse movie of 2023 as
Spider-Man across the spiderverse
debuted just two weeks prior still The
Flash is loads of fun and if you're not
comparing it to one of the greatest
superhero movies of all time it actually
holds up Ezra Miller shines in not one
but two leading roles playing both older
and younger versions of Barry Allen sure
the time travel mechanics make zero
sense but if you're willing to go along
with the Tangled mess of a plot it
offers plenty of laughs and raises some
thought-provoking questions as Barry
begins to understand the consequences of
his meddling besides all the plot holes
in the world are totally worth it to see
Michael Keaton done the bats suit once
more movie studios don't need to pour
$300 million into a movie to end up with
a box office bomb sometimes even
lowbudget comedies can become major
Financial failures take the 2022 romcom
Bros Universal Pictures only invested $
222 million in the film yet it only made
a total of $1 million at the domestic
box office relatively speaking it didn't
cost Universal as much money as larger
scale flops do but a loss is still a
loss regardless Bros is good not so
clean fun while Bros isn't the first
mainstream comedy to feature a gay
couple in leading rol
it does Mark the first romcom from a
major Studio to get a theatrical release
with an almost entirely queer cast this
cheeky comedy is willing to poke fun at
just about everybody it cleverly
satirizes Hollywood pokes fun at pickup
lines and jokes about infighting in the
lgbtq plus Community this happens to be
by sexual awareness week and no one has
acknowledged it I acknowledged that is
true my bad despite being a comedy Rose
also has plenty of emotional heft
viewers Hearts will go out to sarcastic
podcast host Bobby as he learns to open
up and allow himself to be
loved when Gladiator director Ridley
Scott announced that he would Helm
another historical epic fans
understandably got excited the last duel
seemed like a sure bet but when it
stepped up to joust against Halloween
kills on its opening weekend Scott's
film died a horrible death at the box
office even after factoring in the inter
International earnings the movie earned
back less than onethird of its budget a
poor showing for such an accomplished
filmmaker why did it stumble perhaps
viewers expected a bloody Macho battle
more in line with gladiator instead the
movie's marketing was a little bit
misleading Matt Damon and Adam driver's
dualists are no Heroes and the real
protagonist is jod Comer's margarit
after she is brutally assaulted a duel
will decide whether her asent will face
Justice or walk free the same sequence
of events is depicted from the
perspectives of three different
characters but it's quickly apparent
who's telling the truth and who's
deluding themselves for those who simply
wanted chivalry and Carnage The Last
duel was a disappointment but if you're
looking for a mature medieval drama it's
definitely worth a watch if you want to
split hairs Pixar's Lightyear
technically earned back its production
budget of $200 million but it didn't
break even factor in marketing costs and
the fact that the theaters get a
percentage of all ticket sales and it
becomes clear that Lightyear was not the
least bit profitable for Pixar Chief
creative officer Pete doctor reflected
on what Pixar could learn from the
film's failure telling the rap I think
there was a disconnect between what
people wanted SL expected and what we
were giving to them viewers hope to see
more of the Toy Story characters they've
come to love but there's no woody Jesse
or Mr Potato had to be found instead
Lightyear is a movie about the astronaut
that the Buzz Lightyear toy was
apparently based on it was a bold idea
and it turned out to be a bit too
convoluted for audiences to appreciate
Lightyear is considered by many to be
one of the Lesser Pixar movies but it's
still a quality outing from one of the
most trusted studios in animation while
Chris Evans can't quite replace Tim
Allen as Buzz himself he still does a
fine job of portraying the uptight Space
Ranger who learns to loosen up director
George Miller is a master of all genres
after delighting children with his story
of a dancing penguin in Happy Feet and
its sequel he returned to the Wasteland
for the action-packed Epic madmax Fury
Road fans weren't sure whether to expect
talking animals or exploding cars in his
next production but they ended up
getting neither instead they watched
Tilda swienton fall in love with Jen
Idris Elba in The Surreal fantasy comedy
3,000 years of
longing I like it whatever it is I'm
sure it has an interesting
story un fortunately Miller's first film
in 7 years was nowhere near as lucrative
as Mad Max Fury Road against a $60
million budget 3,000 years of longing
made a measly $8 million at the domestic
box office and its International gross
wasn't much better experts say that the
film might have fared better if it had
opened at only a handful of theaters
before sweeping outward that would have
allowed time for the film to gain
traction from positive word of mouth a
strategy that worked wonders for
everything everywhere all at once that
same Year 3,000 years of longing may not
feature War boys and machine guns but it
still captures the same anarchic energy
is Mad Max Fury Road for a film with a
main narrative that takes place almost
entirely in a single hotel room 3,000
years of longing does an amazing job of
taking viewers on a dazzling Journey
Through Time and Space the Northman is a
slippery film to categorize is it an
indie film with the budget of a
blockbuster or a blockbuster with the
production values of an indie the film's
genre defying nature might have been one
of the reasons why it bombed at the box
office movie goers just weren't sure
what to make of it despite a budget of
$90 million plus no small sum invested
in advertising the Northman earned only
$69 million at the box office worldwide
that's a shame as this film from
director Robert Edgars is truly stunning
fans of Edgar's previous films the witch
and the lighthouse will adore the
Northman this visceral movie isn't for
the faint of heart but it's expertly
crafted in all its gruesome Glory the
world Edgars creates feels tactile and
gritty more real than anything else seen
in other fantasy ethics and his Devotion
to keeping the Northman historically
accurate is astounding critics have said
that the film manages to be both modern
and Timeless displaying a contemporary
sensibility despite telling a story
that's been around for thousands of
years The Bleak and brutal tone of the
north men may not be for everyone but
Edgars commits so deeply to its
aesthetic that you can only watch with
slack jawed awe realistic drama films
aren't often expected to earn a whole
lot of money but Warner Brothers was
likely expecting a decent haul from King
Richard thanks to the star power of Will
Smith the $50 million movie earned only
$15 million at the domestic box office
plus an additional 24 million overseas
it doesn't take a mathematician to
figure out that doesn't add up King
Richard needed to compete against the
immensely popular Ghostbusters afterlife
and its simultaneous release on HBO Max
may have also funneled viewers away from
the theater although the movie's
reputation tends to be overshadowed by
the notorious slap the truth is that
King Richard is an timent and honest
movie with the central performance
deserving of the Academy Award for best
actor it's a fresh take on the sports
biopic focusing Less on the young
William sisters and more on their father
and unofficial coach working behind the
scenes Smith throws himself
wholeheartedly into the lead role
embracing the character's Devotion to
his daughters and the immense pressure
he places on them although we never get
to see the sisters earn any of their
numerous Grand Slam titles King Richard
is even more poignant because we know
how it's going to end with two inspiring
Champions Venus and Serena going to
shake up this
world if you want to see a 2022 film
about Naval aviators doing jaw-dropping
stuns with Glenn Powell in a supporting
role top gun Maverick is probably what
you're looking for but surprisingly
that's not the only movie that fits that
description 6 months after Maverick hit
theaters and broke a billion dollars
devotion was released and it promptly
crashed and burned despite its sizable
$90 million budget it only brought in a
bit under $22 million when all was said
and done it's easy to write it off as a
copycat flick but devotion wasn't made
to capitalize on the Top Gun hype
instead it tells the true story of an
American hero that far too few people
know about played by Jonathan Majors
Jesse Brown is a black pilot serving in
the US military during the Korean War
this inspiring story doesn't shy away
from addressing racism and other flaws
in military culture instead it explores
how soldiers are trained to repress
their emotions especially Brown who
finds himself afraid to show any
weakness as the only black man in his
unit Brown may not have the same
Charisma as Tom Cruz's Pete Maverick
Mitchell but Majors more than makes up
for it in dramatic weight if you
appreciate history airplanes and quality
film making then devotion might just be
the movie for you the year 2022 was not
a good one for animated films at Disney
after the failure of Lightyear Disney
suffered another Financial loss with the
film Strange World costing $180 million
to produce and likely an additional $90
million to Market Strange World made
only $73 million at the worldwide box
office and drained the studio of an
estimated
$197 million given the popularity of
Moana and Frozen it's understandable
that audiences were a bit disappointed
to learn that Strange World doesn't
contain any showstopping musical numbers
even Rya and The Last Dragon which
doesn't have a single song in its run
time features elements still familiar to
Disney fans fantasy kingdoms and animal
sidekicks fairy tale musicals may be
what Walt Disney Animation Studios does
best but they deserve credit for trying
to Branch out into other genres right
from its opening sequence Strange World
pays homage to pulpy Adventure Comics at
the same time it deconstructs the
genre's conventions asking why the
heroes of these stories need to conquer
mountains or tame seas in the first
place the protagonist of strange world
just wants to be a farmer and his son
cares more about maintaining balance in
the ecosystem than discover ing new
lands someone forgot to weed the North
Field father what is a weed other than a
plant growing somewhere that you find
inconvenient there's lots of colorful
World building from steampunk airships
to Trippy creatures and also a
surprisingly nuanced commentary on
Humanity's relationship with nature
Strange World arguably may not deliver
what Disney fans hoped for but it still
takes the animation studio in a fresh
Direction despite having a budget of
$100 million and Steven Spielberg's name
attached Westside Story barely earned
back 3/4 of its production budget
whether it's because the film had to
compete against Spider-Man no way home
or because viewers were too busy
comparing it to the original to
appreciated Westside Story failed to
make a profit regardless folks who
skipped it in theaters missed out in the
2021 version of Westside Story audiences
who got to see the musical on the big
screen witnessed the story on a scale
they had never SE seen before the film
boasts some jaw-dropping sets from the
streets of Manhattan to the warehouse
where the Jets and sharks Rumble there's
no correct side in the war between gangs
Mike bce's riff is a scruffy pathetic
boy you can't help but feel sorry for
while David Alvarez is Bernardo shines
as a loyal brother who can't stop
getting into fights Rachel Zigler shines
as Maria who knocks it out of the park
in her film debut and Ariana deos
commands every scene she she's in as
Anita debose took home the best
supporting actress Oscar for her efforts
and when you see Spielberg's adaptation
of the classic musical you'll understand
why whether you're a longtime fan of the
Steven sonheim musical or you've never
experienced his bold take on Romeo and
Juliet the 2021 Westside Story has
something for everyone to enjoy when
Christopher Nolan tried to get movie
theaters back in action with tenant in
August 2020 it likely cost Warner
Brothers as much as $100 million the
movie's underwhelming returns convinced
Warner Brothers to release movies and
theaters and streaming services
simultaneously prompting Nolan to break
ties with the studio the unfortunate
tenant earnings also rippled out to
impact other Blockbuster releases Warner
Brothers pushed back Wonder Woman 1984
by a couple of months while Candyman and
black widow were delayed until 2021
tenet may not be Nolan's best work but
like many of his other films it's a Del
iately crafted mind game the director
experimented with time manipulation in
his films momento and Interstellar but
tenant manages to crank those ideas to
the max it's a Showcase of Nolan's
biggest strengths and weaknesses and
that makes it a must C for any Nolan fan
who's somehow managed to avoid it until
now from backward car chases to reverse
bungee jumping it's easy to get a
headche trying to unravel all of the
time travel mechanics if you thought
that Inception was confusing tenet is on
another level but if you take the advice
of Clans Poe's character Barbara and
just enjoy The Vibes you'll have a good
time don't try to understand
it feed it when Search light Pictures
invested $60 million in Nightmare alley
it was perfectly reasonable for them to
assume that the film would be a huge hit
after all G mod Del Toro had directed
several box office successes including
Pacific Rim and the best picture winning
the shape of water however this tent
pole film about a carnival con artist
collapsed in on itself like a circus
tent earning only $39 million worldwide
perhaps audiences were disappointed it
wasn't a dark fairy tale like del Toro's
most iconic works there are no magical
creatures or fantasy elements in
Nightmare alley although Bradley
Cooper's character Stan claims to have
the ability to read minds he's nothing
more than a really clever scammer
nightmare alley may not have any Kaiju
or sexy sea monsters but there's still
plenty to admire about del Toro's neon
Noir film on the surface it seems to
have nothing in common with his other
projects but if you look a little closer
it's classic deloro the gorgeous set
design is on par with pan Labyrinth and
Crimson Peak and previous Del Toro
collaborators Ron Pearlman and Richard
Jenkins make appearances Kate Blanchett
is also there and naturally she
dominates every scene she appears at
watching nightmare alley is a hypnotic
experience as Stan digs himself deep
deeper and deeper into trouble it's hard
to tear your eyes away Bo is afraid is
another example of an independent
director being given a big budget and
free reign yet somehow attracting fewer
viewers than his smaller more Indie
projects after the critical and
Commercial Success of hereditary and
Midsummer a24 offered ra aser $35
million to make Bo is afraid his biggest
budget yet unfortunately the film earned
measly $1 million at the Box office B is
afraid is either indulgent or ambitious
depending on who you ask it's less of a
traditional horror movie and more like a
surreal dark comedy which may explain
why some fans of his first two films
were disappointed that's not to say it
won't send Shivers of fear down your
spine as B encounters and then runs away
from some truly unhinged characters as
always Walkin Phoenix is in top form his
performance absolutely Nails the
experience of living with paranoia as
everyone seems to be constantly out to
get him his agonizing Odyssey from his
dangerous Hometown to his mom's house
ends in truly Unforgettable fashion
featuring one of the biggest WTF movie
moments of the decade if you can handle
3 hours of anxiety and nervous laughter
Bo is afraid is definitely worth
watching perhaps years down the line
horror fans will be returning to this
intricate film to unpack all its layers
of meaning who knows Bo is afraid might
even earn cult classic St us
someday